What do an icy despot and a crustacean-themed
conqueror have in common?
"Game of Thrones" and "House of the Dragon"
viewers may notice some shared traits.
Spoilers for "House of the Dragon" ahead.
The ending of the second episode of "House
of the Dragon" introduces viewers to Craghas
Drahar, also known as "Crabfeeder," whose
nickname tells you everything you need to
know about his preferred method of execution
and body disposal.
A high-ranking member of the Triarchy, Crabfeeder
has conquered the strategically important Stepstones islands.
As a result, the era's finest seafarer and
reigning Master of Ships, Lord Corlys Velaryon,
isn't very happy.
"I will not have Driftmark beggared while
our king idles himself with feasts and balls
and tourneys."
The "Sea Snake" forms an alliance with disgraced
Daemon Targaryen, and in Episode 3, they face
off with Crabfeeder's forces on the Stepstones.
In a desperate bid to get the win before reinforcements
come in, Daemon hatches a daring plan to use
himself as bait and pretend to surrender to
draw Crabfeeder out from the caves he uses
to avoid dragonfire.
Against all odds, the desperate maneuver works
— and, after a thrilling battle sequence,
Daemon chases Crabfeeder down and kills him.
With his ravaged features and golden face
mask, Crabfeeder is a very memorable-looking guy.
There's a time skip of three years in the
third episode of "House of the Dragon," and
Crabfeeder has been holding the Stepstones
that whole time.
Even so, he seems to go down easily when the
time comes.
Crabfeeder's quick end has some comparing
him to the "Game of Thrones" villain the Night
King, and not in a very good way.
They're both visually interesting and super
threatening villains who mostly just stand
around looking creepy while everyone else
does the majority of the fighting.
And then when it's time for them to die, they're
both dispatched fairly quickly.
Apart from the fact that Crabfeeder isn't
a supernatural threat, there's of course one
significant difference.
By the time Arya Stark stabs the Night King
to death in "Game of Thrones," the villain
has been a looming threat since Season 4.
As such, while the leader of the White Walkers
does go down over the course of a single episode,
at least he's been around for a while.
"What does he want?"
"An endless night.
He wants to erase this world."
Crabfeeder, on the other hand, only gets that
ominous intro at the end of Episode 2.
The show then fast-forwards through all of
his cool moments, of which there must have
been many, considering that he seems to have
been successfully holding the Stepstones for
several years.
We don't even see his gruesome death scene.
Daemon bisects Crabfeeder offscreen.
One would assume "House of the Dragon" is
trying to avoid making the mistakes many fans
think "Game of Thrones" made in its final
season.
With author George R.R.
Martin's increased involvement and the benefit
of hindsight, it's easy to imagine that the
prequel will look to steer clear of the events
that led to rampant criticism of the last
few episodes of "Game of Thrones."
The Night King's swift and, for some, anticlimactic,
downfall after seasons of buildup seems like
the kind of thing "House of the Dragon" wouldn't
be willing to touch with a ten-foot pole.
By introducing Crabfeeder in a "Big Bad" fashion
and doing away with the character after one
episode of hectic battle, "House of the Dragon"
may deliberately be introducing similar-seeming
storylines, but tweaking them so they have
a different impact.
It's also entirely possible that "House of
the Dragon" is using the shorthand of a similar
storyline as a means to build up Daemon as
a shrewd operator.
Still, it's pretty strange that the show's
writers seemingly chose to call back to the
original show's least-loved era.
Unless it's unintentional, which could indicate
a whole different set of issues.